[Música]
hola bienvenidos a la revista digital
donde abordamos los temas más
importantes del ciberespacio en las
redes sociales y los medios de
comunicación de américa latina y el
mundo amor reconoció aquellas
herramientas que contribuyeron a nuestra
nueva normalidad en medio de la pandemia
de kobe 19 aplicaciones móviles que nos
ayudaron a recuperar algo de nuestra
cotidianidad reuniones de trabajo
interacción con nuestros seres queridos
y hasta el entrenamiento físico detrás
de algunas de estas herramientas hubo
una fuerte presencia de latinos en
france24 hablamos con algunos de ellos
empezamos
como es usual a por reveló su lista de
las mejores aplicaciones y juegos del
año en su app store en esta oportunidad
la compañía reconoció aquellas
aplicaciones que demostraron ser
esenciales en medio de la emergencia que
vivimos en 2020 a causa del cobi 19
entre los galardonados y por encima de
grandes y famosas compañías hubo una
fuerte presencia de desarrolladores
latinos que innovaron con herramientas
que nos brindaron una alternativa en
situaciones como la conexión con
nuestros seres queridos el ejercicio
físico en cualquier lugar donde nos
encontremos y la diversión a través de
juegos en total fueron 15 aplicaciones y
juegos que según apple nos hicieron la
vida más fácil más saludable y más
conectada este año ante el confinamiento
la restricción de la movilidad y el
cierre de negocios no esenciales hacer
ejercicio desde casa se volvió una nueva
costumbre por eso wake out se convirtió
en una opción ideal nació hace tres años
y este 2020 fue galardonada como la
mejor aplicación del año para iphone y
es desarrollada por dos guatemaltecos
andrés canella y pedro wunderlich se
describe como un app que brinda una
rutina de ejercicios para cada día y así
romper el patrón
walcott la sede del juego de palabras
entre wake up y walk out que
respectivamente significan despertar y
entrenar no sólo proporciona movimientos
para ayudar a activar el cuerpo sino que
también ayuda a conciliar el sueño y lo
mejor es que cada ejercicio está
diseñado para poder realizarse en
cualquier lugar donde nos encontremos
cuadro wanderley y uno de sus creadores
nos contó cómo se inspiraron en esta
aplicación y cómo es tener éxito en un
mercado internacional
entonces diseñamos wake up pensamos en
ideas y se nos ocurrió que quizás
podemos hacer que la gente haga un poco
de ejercicio en la cama con su almohada
lo lindo del appstore y de diseñar apps
o tecnología es de que no existen
fronteras no es muy diferente a crear un
producto físico los inspiró a que
intente intenten al principio por
supuesto les van a decir que no no les
va a abrir la puerta más que todo o que
no porque son latinos sino que no les
abren la puerta porque no están contando
su historia bien para quienes buscan
conectarse con sus seres queridos
especiales
con niños caribú se convirtió en ese
espacio perfecto la aplicación fue
reconocida por apple como una de las que
lideró una tendencia hacia la utilidad
desarrollada por la cubana max puig
y el español álvaro sabido esta
herramienta es ideal para padres que no
pueden estar presencialmente con sus
hijos todo el tiempo caribú cuenta con
decenas de juegos interactivos y cientos
de libros en su plataforma para que las
familias puedan compartirlos mientras
realizan una videollamada en tiempo real
al bueno sabido nos constó la
importancia de esta aplicación en este
momento que vivimos la manera en la que
los niños se comunican a través de
cuentos a través de dibujar o de juegos
es algo que también les abre a hablar
más de cosas personales y de de su vida
como niños de tres años más que un padre
siempre empleando un interrogatorio de
qué has hecho y que existe en el colegio
tal para que es muy repetitivo es una
experiencia completamente diferente y es
algo que
que realmente está uniendo estas
familias ahora precisamente cuando
tienen que estar separadas prácticamente
llevamos un año sin poder saber mandar a
tres office es tal vez una de las
aplicaciones más originales tiene una
estética retro y está cargada de un
simbolismo y una fuerte influencia
cultural de brasil a pola escogió como
el mejor juego del año para apple tv y
fue creada por los brasileños lucas
matos y joao branch es un juego de
aventuras y recibe el nombre de su
protagonista dándara una heroína cuyo
personaje se basó en la historia de una
guerrera afro brasileña del período
colonial que luchó contra la esclavitud
su desarrollador la describe como una
empoderada que combate a enemigos
empeñados en la opresión que desafíos
tuvieron joao branch nos contó en france
[Música]
estamos pensando en portugués en brasil
pero hacemos el juego en inglés
programando los inicialmente en inglés
[Música]
quieres que la experiencia en inglés sea
muy buena bien calificada la empezamos
así luego la traducimos a portugués por
ejemplo
creo que esa es una característica de
cualquier juego
tienes que sobrevivir es realmente más
complicado depender solamente del
mercado local
tienes que apuntar a lo internacional
otra de las galardonadas son
aplicaciones de grandes empresas que hoy
también crecieron en medio de la
emergencia generada por el cob y 19
disney flash que recientemente llegó a
américa latina recibió el premio como
mejor aplicación para paul tv show
famosa por facilitar las
videoconferencias especialmente en el
teletrabajo fue calificada como mejor
aplicación del año para ipad explain
everything que cuenta con una pizarra
interactiva estuvo entre la reconocida
por favorecer la utilidad al posibilitar
la interacción de forma remota entre
estudiantes y profesores en medio del
cierre de escuelas a nivel mundial para
evitar aglomeraciones
hasta aquí revista digital recuerda que
si quieres repetir este u otro episodio
de nuestro programa lo puede hacer a
través de nuestra página web www punto
frente 4 puntocom
[Música]